[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du 7 8 sociétés votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire vous nous discutons des
sujets qui font l'actualité
depuis plus d'un mois l'actualité
internationale vit au rythme du conflit
en ukraine plus de 4 millions
d'ukrainiens ont fui leur pays depuis
l'invasion ordonnée par delà des murs
poutine il serait trente six mille à
avoir trouvé refuge en france face au
conflit une forte mobilisation s'est
développée en voie de dons soutien
financier accueille les yvelines ne sont
pas en reste et cette solidarité c'est
le thème de ce magazine dont un invité
ce soir laurent marquèrent bonsoir
bonsoir maire de montigny le bretonneux
d'arrière violette bonsoir danseurs
c'est une vie chinoise d'origine
ukrainienne vous accueillez actuel où
une famille qui a fui le conflit et
florent ce turc bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes membre de la team ban ou si ce sont
des bénévoles qui pâtissent et cuisine
dans le cadre de à vos gâteaux et on
espère accueillir bien vite monsieur à
dainville le vice président du conseil
départemental des yvelines alors j'ai
commencé que vous d'arrière violette
vous aviez reçu tv 68 chez vous début du
mois de mars pour un reportage vous avez
accueilli anastasia sa soeur ses nièces
un petit bébé et leurs animaux pourquoi
déjà que vous les avez accueilli 1 déjà
ce sont les gens que je connais et ils
sont partis de leur ville la deuxième
jour
depuis le début de la guerre et carnot
stasi à ma demande est ce qu'on pourrait
venir chez toi je dis bien évidemment on
va te faire ton nécessaire pour vous
aider pour vous accueillir vous sembler
légitime j'imagine les auxiliaires pas
l'excision de réfléchir et l ai dit mais
on a les animaux est ce que ça gêne page
des venets et après on va on va en
reparler mais bien évidemment ça je n'ai
pas et
on a resté à peu près
trois semaines je pense chez moi et
grâce aux efforts céder la mairie des
voisins qui ont fait énormément de
choses pour pour elle et pour que ça
avance très vite on a réussi à le
retrouver aussi le logement est donc
actuellement elles sont déjà déménagé
dans leur maison alors elles ont l'appui
matériel mais comment vont-elles
vont-ils aujourd'hui même les animaux
est ce que la vie a un peu repris pour
elle
psychologiquement bien sûr c'est
difficile parce que les pères les maris
les frères mineurs sont en ukraine elles
sont pas vraiment à l'abri donc bien
évidemment la nervosité
parfois surmonte mais on essaie de faire
ton nécessaire pour
les ssl de ne plus y penser donc les
filles vont collège on a même réussi
aussi grâce à aux efforts de la mairie
de voisins
plus d en installer mettre une fille à
l'école des beaux-arts à versailles
parce que c'est une famille des peintres
et donc elle a été pris directement au
10e à la et la vie continue pour travaux
à la haye ça leur permet de ne pas trop
penser à l'or il n'y a pas que vous qui
a accueilli des familles dès le début du
conflit fin février le jeune ukrainien
sont hébergés par le département c'est
au caucus des mureaux nicolas landry et
céline charles les ont rencontrés
regarder
[Musique]
jean wright my songs and play un guitare
piano au plr de
nidau be l'état
c'est d'être
aux jo wind and
making vidéo ce
un acte actrice iplay india pti
michael leighton baines a laissé
tourisme
is not take you because it's prime
buildings
[Musique]
joe
biden ou
baby normaux mais by faith and
community and lee smith island gold away
6 10
brock est ce
ma femme lit in my tâm en deux grandes
banques us
un des cinq mille photo ou une vidéo
wendy qui rêvent de disques emi
[Musique]
un
stand money for my
family l'école week-end au vert
on distingue un
fan
de star d'high tech a remis 1 de
10%
nous a rejoints en plateau nicolas
dainville bonsoir bonsoir vice président
du département des yvelines et maire de
la verrière donc là on a vu une des
actions menées par le département mais
il ya aussi une collecte qui rassemblait
plus de 110 communes des yvelines les
images du centre où tout cela était
stocké c'est impressionnant 20 semi
remorques sont partis pour la pologne
exactement de plusieurs actes de
solidarité la part des yvelines ya eu le
vote de deux cent mille euros de
subventions allouées jay acte aide donc
dès les premiers jours du conflit qui
vous a tous beaucoup beaucoup affecté et
puis ensuite effectivement des langues
générosité donc avec le plus de 100
commune yvelinoise des yvelinois pour
apporter des dents être de deux
premières descentes et un tel un tel
engouement sachant qu'il ya des toutes
petites communes si je peux me permettre
pour ça qu'ils ont peu d'habitants qui
ont participé aussi
écouter c'est vrai ont été surpris par
l'ampleur de la générosité c'est vrai
que co vide nous avons aussi montré
beaucoup de générosité envers nos
soignants et puis on a eu d'autres notre
drame avec le les réfugiés syriens qui
s'immobiliser quelques verres irois
j'avais pu le constater mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu une ampleur très importante
avec donc tous ces dons des couvertures
des médicaments des ddd des boîtes de
conserve des denrées de première
nécessité dont qui ont été acheminés en
pologne et puis ensuite trois camions
par jour 1 qui partait pour le dépasser
c'est une collecte à laquelle
montigny-le-bretonneux a bien sûr
participé laurent mercan j'imagine ya
pas eu besoin de prier lésigny montant
non alors ça c'est toujours le cas dans
les événements de ce type qu'on se rend
compte finalement de la réactivité la
solidarité des habitants mais je crois
que tout le monde a été extrêmement
touché par le drame qui se passe en
ukraine et que du coup le l'élan a été
très rapide et très fort et on a eu
effectivement sur montigny lors de deux
journées de collecte plus de huit cents
colis plus de 800 cartons qui ont pu
être collectés de produits divers et
nous avons pu aussi avoir une collecte
par le biais des médecins des
pharmaciens l'association des médecins
des trois villages qui eux ont recherché
à collecter des produits médicaux là
pour les personnes qui sont dans les
zones de guerre donc avec des choses qui
permettent de se soigner quand on fait
une hémorragie par exemple donc ça c'est
sûr très particulier sur 13 parties
doivent effectivement à besoins très
spécifiques et là dessus d'ailleurs nous
avons eu le soutien de madame parce
qu'il fallait traduire évidemment sur
les cartons ce qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur qui est très spécifique donc
il ya eu ces deux types de collecte a
effectivement qui se sont faites sur la
vie alors des dons matériels c'est ce
dont ils avaient peut-être le plus
besoin aussi il y aussi des collectes
financière des petites mains des
pâtissiers des pâtissières qui ont mis
leur talent en proa profils y en a une
avec nous assure florence les cercles de
la timba nofit café une vente de gâteaux
sur le marché de maisons laffitte celle
de la team vanille aux généreux concours
vous êtes passé des héros du quotidien
les pompiers les médecins aux réfugiés
ukrainiens et aux ukrainiens sur place
tout à fait en fait notre notre chaîne
de solidarité c'est de venir en aide
également aux plus vulnérables et les
plus vulnérables quand on a appris
ce drame en ukraine tout de suite on
sait enfin on s'est demandé comment on
allait pouvoir aider à notre petit
niveau au delà de participer et
d'organiser des collectes puisque
certaines teams aussi l'ont fait
de ce fait on a organisé cette vente on
a demandé l'autorisation à notre mairie
voilà qui nous l'a accordé et qui nous a
donné une place sur le marché voilà et
on a communiqué avec nos petits moyens
par les réseaux sociaux etc et on a eu
un accueil au delà de ce qu'on aurait
peut-être les choses vous êtes obligé de
retrouver en cuisine choix alors ça
c'était la timonerie parce que là
c'était sur une journée donc c'était de
11h à 19h alors que nous c'était sur le
marché de maisons laffitte donc le
marché qui commence à 8h le matin et
nous à midi on avait plus rien sur notre
stand voilà on avait fait des macarons
j'ai plusieurs traiteur à domicile dans
ma team qu'ils font vraiment des très
joli gâteau et tout est parti mais on
avait on ne pouvait plus voilà et donc
on a quand même récolté près de 2000
euros qu'on a reversé à la croix rouge
en faveur des réfugiés craignent un mois
nicolas dainville on se sent vite
démunis face à un conflit aux portes pas
très très loin de chez nous peut-être ça
fait plus bouger c'est ce qui a aussi
fait que le département s'était aussi
vite mobilisés oui c'est vrai que c'est
aux portes de l'europe c'est un peuple
dont on se sent proche
on a aussi effectivement tout un tout un
système de collecte qui aura un concert
donc vendredi ce vendredi là avec l'
orchestre royal à la chapelle royale de
versailles
d'ailleurs des musiciens hébergés au
campus des mureaux vont pouvoir et
participez donc ça serait un beau
symbole ild l'ukrainien sera entonnée à
la fin du concert pour récolter donc
aussi des financements pour aider au
maximum effectivement ça qu'on est dans
un continent de paix malgré hier au
cosim même plus quand on avait un si je
peux me permettre on n'a pas l'habitude
je suis une génération qui n'a pas du
tout connu les conflits exactement la
rade est donc sage et que à quelques
kilomètres de chez soi le le conflit
résonne de manière peut-être encore
encore plus plus terrible est donc c'est
sûrement ce qui explique aussi cet élan
de générosité
derrière violette est ce que vous avez
changé aussi avec des vues chinois pour
leur dire est ce que vous pouvez
accueillir ou d'autres yvelinois est ce
que le fait que vous soyez d'origine
ukrainien a peut-être joué aussi dans
votre mobilisation peut-être plus forte
alors déjà il ya beaucoup de gens j'ai
pas je peux vous besoin des contacts et
qu'il craint parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont contacté pour
demander est ce qu'on pourrait
accueillir jean et jean est ce qu'on
peut rapporter quelque chose faire
quelque chose et des et
moi même je
je m'occupe pas encore des réfugiés qui
se sont installés à la base de loisirs à
montigny et il ya il ya régulièrement
des besoins pour aller traduire près les
médecins et les infirmières auprès des
questions administratives ou juste venir
apporter de l'aide apportée de s'ouvrir
aux enfants
est également je m'occupe d'une famille
qui a énormément souffert qui a passé un
parcours horrible c'est une petite fille
qui a perdu son père leur leurs
déplacements et donc je sais aussi de
leur apporter de l'aide en particulier
est
également avec les collectes et j'ai
profité des collectes qui était
organisée à la mairie de montigny pour
organiser un envoi dans la ville czerny
vif qui a été fortement bombardée qui a
beaucoup souffert et qui était
malheureusement entouré en cercle et
miné il n'y avait pas de possibilité de
ramener de l'aide humanitaire alors
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'autres qui
venaient nuque raide mais là bas c'était
là ils étaient déjà une catastrophe
humanitaire et donc par mes propres chez
moi par mes propres connaissances j'ai
fait en sorte qu'une partie de cette
collecte qui a été organisée à montigny
et les parties elle a réussi à rentrer
dans cette ville à charny yves et ça
fait chaud au coeur de savoir qu'il y
avait un ami tout petit gars goût amer
mais l'était quand même déposé là bas
aux besoins des gens un travail de
longue haleine j'imagine qui prend
beaucoup de temps
laura merckaert il ya aussi des
partenariats qui ont été mis ligue des
associations locales perspective ukraine
et la chorale accords unis
le chef de choeur est d'origine écrit
ukrainienne finalement il ya beaucoup
beaucoup liens et l'ukraine dans les
yvelines oui il ya des liens forts et
effectivement la présidente de
perspectives ukrainienne est innée
monteyne c'est les cja darricau de
mettre enhco qui a été en lien avec nous
dès le départ dès qu'on a commencé en
réfléchir va montigny sur la façon de
manifester notre solidarité
et puis il ya la chorale accords iniques
a fait aussi différents concerts 1
conserve ce dernier week-end à
guyancourt je crois qu'ils ont collecté
près de 4800 euros et c'est avec eux
effectivement que nous avons pu regarder
comment être plus efficaces dans nos
actions voir de quels types de biens il
y avait besoin pour pouvoir envoyer
là-bas avec le département nous avons pu
faire effectivement des envois
extrêmement massif mais dès le départ
nous avons pu par le biais de ses
associations
envoyer des biens tout de suite
et comme les et madame effectivement on
a des choses ont pu partir même dans des
zones un peu compliqué et je crois quand
j'ai longtemps il n'y a pas de petites
actions en matière de solidarité de
chacun chacun joue sa partition fait ce
qu'il peut et on essaye et c'est vrai
que c'est comme ça qu'on a travaillé
avec saint quentin en yvelines
effectivement il ya eu cette idée
d'accueillir aussi des personnes sur
l'île de loisirs ça ça fait suite à une
discussion que j'ai eue avec le
président de l'agglomération jean michel
fourgous on se disait tous les deux
qu'il fallait imaginer des structures
d'accueil collectif et il est le relais
le l'endroit qui a été trouvé sur l'île
de loisirs nous semblait vraiment
approprié pour ça et donc aujourd'hui
avec la ville et l'association relais
jeunes des prêts qui a été missionné par
la préfecture pour prendre en charge ces
personnes nous essayons les accompagner
au quotidien du mieux possible alors les
membres de la team à vos gâteaux n'a pas
fait que pâtissent est certain aussi du
côté de la team vanilla a accueilli des
familles vous multipliez les initiatives
vous soutenez donc ceux qui sont encore
en ukraine mais ceux qui viennent en
france il ya des pique niques il ya des
collectes ça c'est la team vanille donc
du chesnay joséphine et florence qui
s'occupe de cette team et qu'ils ont
rencontrés lors de cette vente de
gâteaux de famille kényane gtel à ce
jour là voilà qui passait avec leur bébé
leur maman ça a été un moment très fort
voilà j'aime aussi monde était vraiment
très très touché par notre action et ils
ont du coup elles ont pris la team
gainey a pris leurs coordonnées et à
organiser des collectes pour elle et
c'est ce sont des petites actions mais
qui mis bout à bout font voilà donc font
du bien déjà aux personnes qui en
bénéficient mais que l'interview vous en
avez parlé le il y à ce fameux concert à
la chapelle pas l'europe et pas mal
comme je n'aime t à la chapelle ce que
le conflit n'est pas terminé
ça fait un mois mais le conflit ça lui a
bien sûr toujours beaucoup
d'incertitudes et des images
terrifiantes qu'on y découvre chaque
jour donc effectivement c'est important
de continuer à se mobiliser c'est
l'essence de ce concert pour aussi avoir
davantage de 2,2 financement les achats
de billets sont défiscalisées c'est
important les élus si vous passez un
discours simple le département et puis
on aura aussi des habitants qui seront
invitées mais notamment des habitants
qui ont hébergé chez eux des familles
ukrainienne voilà on a eu trois par
exemple à l'intérieur c'est petite ville
donc on a un plus petit nombre de 2,2 de
volontaires mail à l'initiative du de la
préfecture de recenser les fabrique
était capable d'héberger
et la face il a facilité les démarches
notamment pour avoir le statut de
réfugié et puis pour avoir quelques
moyens de survivre dans cette période on
était aussi assez apprécié donc c'est
aussi un concert pour leur dire merci
voilà alors du côté de la vieille dame
ont tiré il ya un choix
qui peut paraître anodin mais c'est qui
sera présenté le 13 avril prochain lors
du conseil municipal vous faites un
jumelage avec une ville ukrainienne
c'est la ville d'oyonnax oui alors
justement on pense que c'est tout sauf
anodin
j'entendais l'autre jour d'ailleurs le
président de l'association des maires de
france david lisnard qui lui aussi va se
lancer dans cette démarche l'a appelée
l'île de france a à faire de même de se
lancer dans un jumelage solidaire parce
que en fait avec mon équipe nous sommes
posé la question de la décollecte de
l'accueil de réfugiés ou de dons qu'est
ce que l'on pouvait faire et l'un des
attributs d'une collectivité d'une ville
c'est de pouvoir se jumeler et donc je
me suis dit que nous jumelée avec une
ville ukrainienne serait une très belle
façon pour la france de façon générale
et pour nous à montigny de marquer notre
solidarité vis-à-vis du peuple ukrainien
c'est important jumelage alors un
jumelage ça apporte d'abord une force
symbolique importante
ça manifestent auprès du peuple
ukrainien un soutien tangible j'ai
évidemment pour pouvoir mettre en place
ce jumelage rencontrées par visio c'est
davantage de la technique aujourd'hui
j'ai pu rencontrer le maire de la ville
d'eu dolina avec laquelle nous allons
nous jumelées et qui était extrêmement
touchée que nous puissions avoir cette
démarche avec eux c'est une ville qui
est à l'ouest de l'ukraine donc qui est
aujourd'hui
essentiellement une ville qui accueille
des réfugiés des zones de guerre et donc
je lui ai proposé que nous puissions
être en relation pour voir les besoins
qu'ils pourraient avoir pour accueillir
ces populations est comme ça nous au
niveau des collectes que nous ferons ou
des dons que nous collecterons ça nous
permettra de pouvoir cibler ceux dont
ils ont réellement besoin pour pouvoir
le faire et puis derrière l'objectif
c'est de déboucher sur un jumelage réel
une fois que nous l'espérons la
situation sera revenue à la normale et
donc d'engager une relation entre entre
une ville ukrainienne est une ville
française la ville de montigny avait
déjà fait ça il ya 33 ans presque jour
pour jour avec un village roumain
l'époque où chaouch escou voulait raser
toutes les toutes les toutes les
villages tous les villages de campagne
et parce qu'il s'était entendu avec un
diplomate français et il était
francophile ceausescu stand de ses
qualités c'est rare qualité il s'était
engagé s'il y avait un jumelage à ce
qu'on ne touche pas à cette commune et
aimante il y avait choisi un jumelage
avec eux ce village de l'omc avec lequel
nous sommes toujours jumelées
aujourd'hui est donc cette tradition là
j'ai pensé que c'était quelque chose
d'important et c'est pour ça que nous
souhaitons nous engager dans cette dans
cette démarche vous espérez pouvoir un
jour vous rend à dolina sûr et nous
avons un réel intérêt à ce que ça se
passe parce que c'est une ville
qui est extrêmement intéressante sur le
plan culturel et qui est en plus une
ville dans laquelle il ya une école
francophone ce qui veut dire qu'on peut
avoir des relations intéressantes entre
les enfants de cette école et les
enfants de montigny donc un véritable
jumelage avec de réels partenariats
derrière les plus grands ce turc
l'avenir proche pour à vos gâteaux avec
l'ukraine nous allait continuer oui ses
collègues ses ventes de gâteaux bah oui
tout à fait bon alors il nous faut
l'accord bien entendu de nos mairies
voilà mais oui la team dani
la timba nos fip il ya d'autres il ya la
team de joinville le pont après on est
plusieurs officiels ou si elle a tout à
fait plusieurs dans paris donc oui oui
on va continuer et puis il ya des
collectes aussi qui sont organisées dans
ma team j'ai une bénévole qui accueille
une famille ukrainienne
donc là on va essayer justement de faire
ses ventes en faveur des familles qui
sont accueillis dans notre ville on a
quand même plusieurs et nicolas d'un
vilain ce qu'on peut imaginer une autre
collecte de comme elle a pu être
organisée avec les 110 communes qui sont
portés volontaires peut-être plus tard
des financements pour reconstruire parce
qu'on a vu les images de deux bâtiments
extrêmement détruit tout est
envisageable c'est vrai que sur la
poursuite de la collecte on a toujours
des verreries roi des yvelinois qui
apporte des dons donc c'est vrai que on
peut très bien imaginer que l'opération
se poursuivre et puis ça que les y vibre
toujours répondu présent dect est aussi
pris aux côtés des libanais suite à
l'explosion dramatique
à beyrouth
tout et tout est envisageable en
fonction de la suite de l'actualité en
tout cas les évident quand même été très
réactif grâce à aux yvelinois grâce aux
élus grâce aux agents pour
vraiment répondu présent dans un moment
qui le justifier oui des agents parfois
municipaux à versailles c'est des agents
municipaux qui ont congé même les dons
jusqu'en pologne d'arrière violette j'ai
commencé avec vous je vais terminer avec
vous
quelle va être la suite pour vous l'a
bien compris vous avez continué à vous
investir vous espérez pouvoir retourner
aussi en ukraine bien avait des mains
mais tout le monde espère d'y revenir au
plus vite possible pour reconstruire
pour revivre pour revoir notre beau pays
qui
qui nous qui nous manque énormément
mais malheureusement ces moments c'est
difficile d'imaginer parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de maisons détruites il ya
beaucoup de dangers comme les mines les
missiles qui sont toujours dans les
villes et ça fait un peu peur l'avenir
mais bien évidemment on va s'investir
jusqu'au bout et espérait que la guerre
a sera terminée au plus vite possible on
va être dans un futur proche merci à
tous les quatre d'être venu sur notre
plateau c'est la fin de ce sept huit
sociétés vous avez entendu des villes
des associations de gens qui se
mobilisent n'hésitez pas à aller sur les
divers réseaux sociaux pour ne rien
manquer de ce qui se passe notamment le
concert ce 8 avril à la chapelle royale
du château de versailles merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro et bien
sûr d'ici là prenez soin de vous
il
[Musique]